era maio de 1986
eu tinha apenas 5 anos e estudava em uma
escola de uma cidadezinha que perto
chamada belo campo era escola de freiras
era a melhor escola da cidade
eu estava nessa escola e morava nessa
cidade porque os meus pais muito jovens
na época já com três filhas eu a filha
mais velha eles passaram em um concurso
público cada um deles e foram morar
nessa cidade e essa escola escola onde
estava as crianças das pessoas que mais
tinham dinheiro na cidade tinha um filho
do médico tinha um filho deixe seu filho
de um farmacêutico e eu meu pai era
bancário a minha mãe era funcionária
pública e eles quis desde cedo que iriam
dar pra gente a melhor educação
e aí quando foi um dia eu estava nessa
escola e um colega chegou pra professora
e falou assim tinha eu não quero sentar
do lado dessa mega preta que ele me
falou aquilo eu me olhei e não entende o
que é aquilo que iria dizer
imediatamente a professora me tirou do
lado dele e me levou para o outro lado
da sala
aí a coisa complicou porque ele me
trouxe uma realidade que até então não
conhecia eu era diferente dos outros
alunos
eu não era querida naquele lugar ea
professora efetivou
esse fato me tirou e colocou do outro
lado
eu sempre fui muito chorona nesse
momento comecei a chorar e não parei
mais
eu fui pra casa chorando eu chorei a
tarde inteira e minha mãe tentava
conversar comigo e não sabia o que fazer
ela já tinha pensado em ir lá bater na
professora
para matar o menino essas coisas de mãe
mas ela não sabia o que fazer e aí
quando ela não sabia mais o que fazer já
era noite começou passar na televisão o
concurso de miss brasil e ela me falou
que assistiu concurso com ela e eu fui
mulheres lindas brancas dos cabelos
longos e olhos claros e eu que tinha
passado o dia inteiro dizendo pra minha
mãe que eu não queria ser negra que eu
queria ser branca porque ela tinha me
feito daquela cor e eu falava se mãe
porque você não corta o meu cabelo igual
ao de angélica
então o que é que eu não sou igual a
paquita da xuxa era referência que a
gente tinha de beleza nos anos 80
e aí começa aquele concurso de miss e
minha mãe lei geral
olhou e viu que tinha uma mulher negra
no meio delas e ela me explicou
cada estado brasileiro está representado
por uma mulher e o estado de são paulo
um dos mais importantes do país está
representado por uma mulher negra
você viu como você é importante existir
uma mulher que representa sua beleza
você tem que parar com isso para de
bobagem
e aí a gente foi assistindo aquele
concurso eu escolhi um eu escolhi miss
rio grande do sul era loira dos olhos
verdes cabelos lisos e compridos
eu falava eu quero que ela ganhe e minha
mãe chamando a minha atenção para a
mulher negra e saíam voltavam às que
foram classificadas voltará às 20
voltará às 15 voltará às 10 e todas elas
está uma mulher negra
quando chegam entre as três acredito que
minha mãe foi aliviada e falou assim nós
pronto você está entre as três mulheres
mais bonitas do brasil tá bom pra você
aquela loura lá do óleo vegetal
junto a ela que vai ganhar ela é mais
bonita e neste ano 1986 pela primeira
vez na história do concurso de miss
brasil
foi eleita a mulher negra chamada deise
nunes eu geórgia nunes e aí minha mãe
chegou pra mim e fala você está entre as
mulheres mais bonitas do brasil
isso hoje a gente conhece como
representatividade
naquela época não existia
representatividade da mulher negra na
televisão e hoje ainda existe
eu cresci em um ambiente de classe média
que ainda hoje é habitado por uma grande
maioria branca nas escolas onde eu
estudei
eu sempre era a única menina negra da
escola eu não me sentia representada era
como se estivessem no lugar
os meus pais se esforçaram muito para
que a gente freqüenta essas escolas eram
escolas caras nós nos mudamos para
vitória da conquista
pouco tempo depois deste fato e uma
coisa que minha mãe disse naquele dia me
marcou muito
ela olhou pra mim e falou assim você
nunca mais vai deixar ninguém dizer que
você não é bonita você nunca mais vai
baixar sua cabeça para esse tipo de
agressão e naquela época acredito que
minha mãe não tinha muita noção que nós
como nós temos hoje do que é a condição
da mulher negra dentro da sociedade e eu
cresci assim eu cresci acreditando que
eu podia tudo através do grito através
do desaforo
e quem é que já ouviu nossa mas aquela
mulher desaforada né
o mega brava olha como é que pode
mas as mulheres negras são tão fortes
elas são tão bravas mas eu era chorona
eu não queria ser brava eu não queria
ser desaforada e porque tudo precisava
ganhar no grito porque em todas as
coisas que eu fazia eu precisava ser
duas três quatro vezes melhor do que
aquela minha colega branca que não tinha
não fazia tanto esforço para conquistar
eu não entendia muito bem isso
quando eu entrei na faculdade é indo no
ônibus pra faculdade eu encontrei um
colega e eu observei aquele ônibus não
tinha ninguém negro só tinha ele
eu olhei pra ele ele me olhou ele sorriu
pra mim e aí ele veio falar comigo
quando ele veio falar comigo é ele se
apresentou e coincidentemente nós dois
estávamos na mesma sala e nós estudamos
durante cinco anos juntos e na primeira
semana de aula e disse pra mim você
sabia que nós dois
fazemos parte dos 2% da população negra
que está dentro das universidades
nós somos apenas 2% nós dois somos muito
importantes
nelsinho nome dele um grande amigo
eu ouvi aquilo e me lembrei de uma fala
do meu pai quando tinha nove anos de
idade e eu comecei a passar na televisão
a libertação de nelson mandela
eu cheguei pro meu pai falecido pai
porque esse homem todo o lado por todos
aquela festa acontecendo ficou tanto
tempo preso
ele falou porque ele lutava para que os
brancos fossem iguais aos negros e aí
saí da faculdade eu não me sentia
pertencente a essa cidade e eu quis ir
embora e fui morar em são paulo
quando eu cheguei em são paulo eu fui
convidada para participar junto com um
amigo da gravação de um clipe da cantora
paula lima e eu neste momento estava
querendo descobrir o mundo querendo
descobrir coisas novas e eu cheguei
neste clipe eu vejo várias mulheres
negras com os cabelos enormes com
turbantes aquelas mulheres
lindas eu me senti exatamente igual eu
me sentia na minha escola de grande
maioria branca
eu sentia como se não pertence àquele
lugar porque eu tinha meu cabelo alisado
há 18 anos
eu estava vestida com roupas comum
eu fui me diminuindo diminuindo
diminuindo quando eu estava na porta do
banheiro encostada e aí eu me perguntei
quem sou eu
eu cheguei em casa me olhei no espelho
eu comecei a chorar e eu percebi que
tinha 18 anos que não sabia como era o
meu cabelo tinha 18 anos que não sabia
quem era eu eu resolvi naquele momento
eu queria ter o meu cabelo de volta e
foi um processo um processo bem longo
para conseguir isso
eu não fiz uma maioria das meninas fazem
que raspar o cabelo e aí deixa o cabelo
crescer livre naquela época eu coloquei
um aplique e aquele aplique parecia de
taís araújo na televisão que ela era a
primeira helena negra de manoel carros e
viveu dez nomes na mente e vem de novo a
representatividade e então eu fiquei um
ano e meio aquele cabelo me achando a
taís araújo porque eu agora estava
representada e no dia que eu fui fazer
uma manutenção daquele cabelo tirei
aquele cabelo e no que eu tirei aquele
cabelo amiga que tirou falou se você não
vai colocar o cabelo na sua cabeça
uma pessoa que tem um cabelo desse não
tem necessidade de usar um cabelo gente
morta na cabeça
eu falei tá bom eu vou experimentar
eu fiquei dois dias sem sair de casa e
quando olhei no espelho de novo eu
chorei porque naquele momento eu
consegui ver quem eu era e eu não sabia
lidar com aquela pessoa
eu não sabia lidar com quem eu era eu
não sabia lidar com george e uma amiga
chamada ivete chegou na minha casa e ela
falou assim você precisa ter forças
porque é muito difícil a sociedade nos
embranquece e você está redescobrindo a
sua negritude
e depois disso essa amiga começou a me
emprestar livros ea me dar livros para a
lei
o conhecimento liberta o conhecimento
cura e foi através desses livros e foi
conhecendo autoras negras mulheres
negras que eu não tive a oportunidade de
conhecer na escola que eu nem sabia que
existia que eu fui entendendo todo esse
processo que o nosso país fez com a
gente de nos ensinar como nós devemos
ser de nos ensinar como nós devemos
deixar de ser
e no brasil há a nossa história foi
muito cruel e é muito cruel
o racismo é algo presente dentro dos
ambientes nós estamos hoje em quase
todos os lugares que eu entro eu observo
quanto as pessoas negras têm nesses
lugares
eu frequento em vitória da conquista
muitos lugares de classe média lugares
badalados da cidade
e nesses lugares a grande maioria sempre
branca e nós percebemos uma coisa muito
interessante que esse fato à negritude
está relacionada à pobreza à negritude
está relacionada à exclusão e quando
você escuta ao mas tem muito negro
romancista a gente é ensinado a não
gostar de quem a gente é a gente não é
representado e foi nesse momento quando
eu comecei a descobrir quem eu era e
descobrir a importância que eu tinha e
descobrir o quanto era interessante e
geórgia
independente da cor da minha pele
eu começo a perceber o mundo diferente
eu começo a perceber que as novas
construções não estão em que nós somos
não estão nos nossos padrões
eu começo a perceber porque você segura
a sua bolsa porque o seguro minha bolsa
quando passa um menino negro pela
calçada ea travessa rua
porque os relacionamentos com mulheres
negras
hoje no brasil são as mães solo a grande
maioria das mães solo de onde vê isso
de onde vem essa exclusão de onde vem a
diminuição do valor dessa mulher que é
simplesmente objetificada pelo corpo que
tem
quando começa a observar essas coisas eu
comecei a entender que muito além do que
estava por fora
muito além de assumir um cabelo eu
precisava saber quem era por dentro eu
precisava saber o que estava dentro de
mim e aí neste momento eu precisei
retornar para vitória da conquista é o
meu pai adoeceu e eu voltei pra cá e
quando eu cheguei aqui a minha grande
dificuldade era eu não quero viver que
essa é uma cidade que não me aceita e
mais um momento é preciso mais uma vez
eu preciso me reconectar com essa
realidade
o meu pai faleceu e eu resolvi ficar no
que eu resolvi ficar eu comecei a ter um
outro olhar para essa cidade e perceber
e vitória da conquista
como meu lugar de origem o meu lugar de
fala e começa a trabalhar em mim
a minha percepção sobre as outras
pessoas porque as pessoas são racistas
porque aquele menino não queria sentar
no meu lado quando tinha seis anos de
idade porque hoje quando entrou em um
bar aconteceu recentemente
eu entrei e aí eu observei uma cena
muito interessante
vários homens é estavam site tinha
acabado de sair de uma partida de
futebol e eles entraram em um bar que eu
estava com as amigas no meio deles já
tinha um rapaz negro no bairro eu era a
única moça negra enquanto as bolsas
estavam todas arrumadas e perfumadas
eles chegaram eles chegaram sujos né do
futebol
e aí o homem negro chegou em mim e falou
assim você tem uma beleza singular foi
muito obrigada
ele quando você entrou todo mundo te
olhou
eu fui eu percebi isso você é afronta as
pessoas entendendo que aquilo era um
elogio eu continuar a conversa e
perguntei porque afronta e aí ele falou
quando você chega com esse cabelo
assumindo ser quem você é você afronta
as pessoas e eu disse para ele eu não
vim aqui afrontar as pessoas
eu vim aqui só tomar uma cerveja e aí eu
te pergunto como nós construímos os
nossos afetos como nós somos ensinados a
amar é pela cor da pele é pelo que o
outro é é pelo que o outro tem é pela
ideia que nós temos do outro
nós construímos os nossos a festa por
aquilo que nós somos por dentro
no dia que eu entendi quem eu era e
aprendi a me amar como eu sou
neste dia eu entendi que eu posso ser
afecto pra quem eu quisesse ser da forma
como eu quisesse seja afeto construa fat
distribua afeta muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]